we dumped ice four boxes of dirty and as
I'm sure Dominique welcome ladies and
gentlemen my name is de min kovalevsky
and it is my honor to be your house
today welcome to this room I would like
to welcome also those who follow us on
the channels of the European Commission
and elsewhere on the Internet a handful
of housekeeping remarks we have two
parts the first part is the train of
memory on the 27th of January is the
International Day of Holocaust Memorial
on this day the authorities of Tuscany
organized the train of memory
this feud a long travel from Florence to
Auschwitz is an opportunity for more
than 700 Italians to talk mentioning
important subjects like European
heritage and everything that is
connected to the second world war and
civil responsibility during their stay
in Poland an important moment is the
visit to the German Nazi death and
concentration camp Auschwitz Birkenau
it's also a unique opportunity to listen
to the testimonies of Italians and poles
who were saved from the Holocaust this
project has been now run for the 15th
time and that's the first time part of
the meeting the second is the Civic
dialogue these have continued in the
countries of EU since 2015
members of the European Commission visit
cities throughout Europe and speak with
citizens about the problems and future
of Europe listening to what the citizens
have to say in Poland a very good news
we are a record holder here because it's
already the 136 dialogue of 1300 that
have been organized in this term of the
European Commission
please let me share with you some
technicalities at your disposal there
are
those headsets which let you listen to
the interpreters channel one polish
channel to English and channel three is
Italian polish translation channel
number two English translation and
channel number three Italian translation
I'd like to tell you as I mentioned
before that we are followed on the
channels of the European Commission and
elsewhere on the internet we present on
Twitter and Facebook
hashtag EU dialogue please switch off or
set into silent mode all your mobiles
sorry but this is always a thing worth
remembering now let's welcome our
magnificent guests the first
vice-president of the European
Commission France timmermans
[Applause]
the rector of their galamian university
professor Wojcik novak deputy mayor of
the municipality of Krakov boguslav
kashmir the president of the region of
Tuscany
Enrico Rossi
[Applause]
so glad to hear such a warm applause the
director of the representation of EU in
Poland ambassador Marek powder we have
with us also professor of contemporary
history professor Giovanni Cassini who
is the Italian moderator of our parts
the part that pertains to the train of
memory may also welcome representatives
of the European Parliament ambassadors
and consoles but especially warm I'd
like to welcome sisters Andrea and
Tatiana Buchi and Lydia maximovich from
Poland who are survivors of the
Holocaust
[Applause]
they are the ones who will deliver the
testimonies in the first part but before
that may invite to the stage rector of
the Agila university professor Novak the
floor is yours
[Applause]
GW painful good morning ladies and
gentlemen welcome welcome most cordially
all of you please don't let me mention
once again all the names and functions
as the Minka Villa visca has welcomed us
all may I welcome you with all my heart
to the Lumina University here to kaku
kaku vent the alone in university de mer
is certain to prove is certain unity the
Jagiellonian is the oldest university in
this country and one of the oldest in
europe for six hundred and fifty-five
years it has been fully active in
education and as I always emphasize in
bringing up even when Poland was wiped
away from the map of Europe
and when we had no full serenity the
University was there it persisted and it
fulfilled its mission we proud of our
graduates please let me remind you of
nicolaus copernicus Carroll of Iowa much
better known as john paul ii and for
literary reasons member rasca the poet
yet in the university like in poland in
this city in in europe
there have been hard times today you
have visited today you have discussed
the tragedies of the Second World War
the Holocaust the show the destruction
the university has also lived through
such a time in the second months of
occupation on the 6th November 1939 the
German powers authorities ordered to
arrest 183 professors of the University
then transported to the camp in Saxon
Heusen a day that a university always
commemorates not only for the sake of
history not only in respect for the
people most of whom died but for the
young ones so that we knew what
chauvinist means what lack of Tolerance
is and what lack of understanding
denotes what totalitarianism really is
ladies and gentlemen here I am
addressing especially our young guests
you will have an opportunity to talk to
people who participated in those
dramatic events an opportunity to visit
ashes Birkenau and I must say that
what your members said saying that
having been there after this profound
experience after seeing ashes Birkenau
nothing will remain the same this is a
message to you to the young generation
never allow that lack of tolerance
nationalism xenophobia because they led
to such depravity because there is no
other way the word than this that
describes it thank you very much for
taking up this effort your visit is no
tourism you very well seminars
literature discussing things together
please remember out that throughout your
adult life if a university succeeds to
share this with a young generation this
means that the university fulfills its
mission may I now wish you that this
meeting remains long in your memory
welcome to the AG alone Ian University
otherwise gross the beauty and now it is
time for mbaku suave Kashmir deputy
mayor of the city of Krakow mr.
president your magnificent director
distinguished ladies and gentlemen
welcome to the beautiful city the royal
capital city of Krakow the city of
history and culture the city were for
centuries we have successfully respected
one another poles Lithuanians Russians
Ukrainians Jews Armenians all those
nations in Krakov were living they
worked here they supported one another
welcome to the city of a magnificent
University the University whose presence
in Krakov
is part of this style of mutual respect
to let me welcome you to the city that
is called as I've exchanged some
comments here the Florence of the north
yes we are a city very much like
Florence and I believe that we do plenty
to keep up this link I welcome you to
the city that has very strongly and
sorrowfully experienced the last events
in Gdansk a word can kill but it can
also heal the situation the contact may
this mutual exchange of experience be
for all of you an experience of good an
experience that builds a perspective an
experience that creates the beauty of
this world
welcome to crack off
thank you very much mr. mayor we are
opening the first part of our meeting
and may I now pass the floor to my
Italian counterpart professor Giovanni
good Seany
[Applause]
jancuga Dominique Thank You Dominica
good morning
this morning we discovered the three
stories we're gonna tell you today start
from the same point I mean in Belarus we
didn't know it before I found a small
sign of what has been and what the
Europe will be a space an area where
national belongings cannot be wiped out
but they can be enriched through a
cultural moment of identities our
testimonies today will tell us their
lives to get out of the a bill this bill
that will never leave them as a
particular meaning a particular impact
on young people our faith our belief is
that the old word happened will be kept
in our hearts and if you agree with me
we can invite them onto the floor
[Applause]
Vasa could we invite our guests
professor would you please invite our
guests please join us andrean tatianna
Buchi
Lydia maximovich
[Applause]
okay a little more we are ready to start
off together wave andre and titania our
testimonies of this session we do have
another tale of what we have done
yesterday I'd like to give them the
floor and and they will probably tell
what they were not able to tell people
yesterday good morning everyone
Jean Dubreuil the only two words I
remember in Polish
unfortunately this point
I came here to Poland many times your
language is very difficult it's pretty
hard to learn some words maybe just
because of my age we are very honored to
be here and we'd like to start off with
our story when we were arrested in
Rijeka where we were living we were six
and four years old we are the youngest
survived youngest Italian survivors or
the concentration camps some Germans
together with fascists came to arrest us
we were first brought to the peripheries
of react E and then we to get through a
rise Auslan camp after spending some
nights there we to travel by cattle car
we got to bacon ER after four days
there were no trucks yet that the cooled
lead to the butanol camp trucks started
to work in May later on Jin Qin good
morning everyone so we got to be okay
now on the 4th of April 1945 for its
some believable for example well take
into consideration all the numbers that
May of all these dates there was a huge
mess after we went off the train and the
first selection was made some of the
people were broked into the lorries and
into the into the coaches and they were
gazed immediately and we we were
undressed we were there been a decent
station and the women were cut the air
and we were tattooed as well you didn't
have your name anymore and you had to
learn your number by heart so my number
was seven six four eight and three I
don't remember to be honest if we were
called by our number but we didn't have
a name there in the concentration camps
but yeah of course my sister my cousin
was with us I don't remember someone
calling us by name or by number we were
trying to get used to these conditions
you know children have a spirit of
adaptation we didn't cry
I don't remember crying or using the
bathrooms to be honest we were in the
Barack dedicated to children there was a
small group of children there were not
many children but it was there were a
few as Andrew said we tried to get used
to this life and we realized that we
were Jews we there were some block over
that told us that we were Jews there
were there only women we had to deal
with because most of the women were
working in to the camp
and we tried to suck this life you know
as a child we tried to accept that we
tried to get in to terms with this life
you know we were a child and you were
given this life and you know children
have a huge spirit or deaf DAP tation
and and there is another thing I'd like
to stress here my mother tried to
deceive us in the evening and she kept
saying to us our name and surname
otherwise we would have forgotten that
my name is Tatiana but on the documents
my name is Liliana and my mother told me
that remember that you your name is
Liliana Liliana Bucci and she kept
saying this because in this way would
never forgot my name who is later when
we were freed when we had the chance to
go back to Italy and then there is
another thing I'd like this ties out he
is here one of the block over that kept
us remember that one day you were
standing line and you will be asked to
join your mother try to refuse this
offer this proposal we did have the
and unfortunately for example cause
indeed not had did not hear our
suggestion and when we standing in line
but serger together weave together when
18 children instead of meeting the
mother they were deported to know young
gamma close to Amburg they underwent
some experiments they suffered a lot and
when American allies were about to enter
the city
he was probably the 28th of April they
were broke to this cool of Berlin
boozing in the periphery of Hamburg
before hanging hanging them on purchase
oak they were stunned and Sergio was the
only Italian who was in this group and
the story was discovered by a German
journalist and thanks to him we have a
sort of cemetery where we commemorate
these 19 children we record a improve in
semantics alqasas' cambian el mocambo
HS on Hydra colori i triple or innocence
okay yamaneika chica go she recalled an
opera good camp unknown intruder visa a
Sona persona Katie sorry don't know it
she offer no ANCA casa da mangiare
Ricardo Benicio cachoeira in a Jeep
iseul kohinata questa machina a residue
tone also that true so a key reversal eg
no Keanu tabali
Delano Italia delivered to the salami
no bambini / KO recalled the internal
cuesta jeep so tain't about being on a
persona adult but cheaper to know just
rattled otoki-san / mad at auschwitz
ankyrin popeye some perk a channel port
at a hospital / hey Lucy say no visit
Otto channel
dato DePrima CUDA my question on record
operation oh poor tato vicino a Katowice
a toy the Katowice semen that the Abraha
a a privately owned neshama miyashita
true are equal support in prague we
could never find this place and there
was this kind of orphanage where
definitely we had a better life than in
auschwitz but there was no love there
and there we started attending school we
stayed in Prague for a year and one day
we were called and they asked so who of
you is Jewish and two people stepped
took a step to twins boy and two of us
this free children were with us both in
beer canal and for the whole year in
Prague but if truth be told neither my
sister nor icon from them can remember
them and we only remember about them
just raising their arms to answer the
question so we left with military plane
and we were taken to England I'm sorry
in a beautiful town named Link field
where a gathering Center for Jewish
children that survived the concentration
camp was built both hidden and survivals
of hidden children and survivors from
the concentration camps and there we
were born
can they we were asked what happened
where we came from we said were from
Italy and we told our tale and after a
bit of English classes we were sent to
public school a beautiful one
whereas the school in Prague was a talk
building where teachers were very strict
because if you moved a bit or if you
didn't know the answer or if your answer
was a bit harsh
then you had to give them your hand and
they would use a stick I wouldn't stick
to kind of beat you and that was their
way of teaching but England was a
totally different country at least for
us and there we found our new family and
something really important happened
there one day the director of this place
called us separately and she showed me a
picture do you know them she asked and I
said yes there are my mum and dad and
then under confirmed as she can say that
very fortunately very likely mum and dad
survived the world the war they met
again in rekha in the move to Trieste
and they started right away looking for
us but since we said they were dead it
was hard to prove that so mother
remembered about something very
important this picture was taken the day
of their wedding and when we were living
in Rey calm before the our history began
mother
took this picture with her for us to
give a goodnight kiss to our dead and so
we remembered perfectly about this
picture and that's how we managed to get
back home after all
bureaucratic documents and steps that
were that needed to be taken care of in
England remembered our name and surname
and we knew we were Italians and that
picture and all of these together all
these data were very important for us to
start living again together with our
family we also have to remind you that
during our stay in Birkenau we learned
German and there was the common language
between us and the children and in
Prague we were the only two Italians and
we and by that time we had forgotten our
own native language and we started
speaking Czech and then once we moved to
England we spoke English now it is very
important to be - it was very important
back then and it's really important
right now as well because it makes it
makes it easier for us
thank you each in Korea thank you thank
you very much we arrived to Italy after
a beautiful trip we went through the
channel of England and we started off
from Victoria Station in England a
finger remember where I was on the 5th
of December 1946 and we arrived in
Calais and there we got on a beautiful
train and I remember that as it were the
Orient Express because we had a
beautiful car and the train stopped in
many different stations and every time
we both got off and we were very good at
jumping the rope
and we used to do that until that train
was not living again so we had to get on
and eventually we arrived in Roma
tiburtina that the train stopped and we
got off and at the very beginning of the
platform a car was waiting for us and
there stood our mother waiting for us we
could recognize her as our mother
because she was back at being the mother
of the pre-war times and we were there
we together with a social assistant and
she delivered us somehow to our mother
she greeted us goodbye and she left
because she was going back to England
it was kind of a trauma for my sister
and I for us because we definitely
recognized our mother but maybe we were
afraid of starting of a new life because
she was because our mother was in the
station we have the very small part of a
Jewish community in Rome and we were
kind of overwhelmed by these people that
showed us pictures of children asking us
if we had seen them but they were all
speaking Italian and that was a language
that for us by that time we had
forgotten and instead of crying because
we had found our mother again we cried
because the social assistant was leaving
later on we discovered there was real
pain and for our mother but she was so
good that she did not want anything more
than we could give her at that time so
we were not obsessed with her feelings
she was really good and after a short
stay in Naples because searches mother
were the sister of our mother had gone
back to Naples - and she reunited with
her husband and they had a son so we met
our new cousin and then we left for
Trieste while the London to Rome trip
was a dream trip the room to Trieste the
trip was terrible we were in third class
with wooden chairs that were not
comfortable at all
and I remember we were tedious and we
complained
for the whole trip because it was really
uncomfortable the train was stopping
very often and in our car
there was a very distinguished gentleman
who gave us his pillow because by then
when you could rent a pillow to be a bit
more comfortable and he gave us his
pillow we got to Trieste that became our
new city our new home because rekha
after the war became Yugoslavia and VA
car today is in Croatia for the first
time there was my first time when I met
our Father because he left when I was
around 10 months old and by then I had
become 7 so I was really curious about
the physical aspect of my father so I
kept on asking mother during the whole
trip how will father be how will he be
it was really funny with our mother we
spoke German then with our father we
started speaking English and between the
two of us we spoke check which is the
language we were speaking best at that
time and there was a language that no
one could understand so there was our
secret language we could say whatever we
wanted and nobody would understand us
thank you thank you Andra Thank You
Tatiana
you see we have two European citizens
under litter because what is Europe it's
a pillar it's a cushion it's a
solidarity network that is built after
the tragedy and that their trip
throughout all Europe was a witness to
it's a Europe that takes you back home
but that opens you to the rest of the
world so I think that's a great message
to deliver
Lidia is our polish part this morning
she has a very similar yet very
different history from the one you have
just heard but it's the same reason that
takes her here and now she will tell us
about it
[Applause]
welcome everyone my name is Lydia
maximovich I am one of the last living
witnesses that can bear witness to that
story because it has been 74 years since
this terrible thing the youngest person
that was staying there was a teenager at
this point
this man is an elderly person and cannot
meet young people such wonderful young
people as a meeting today so my story
was somewhat different from what you
heard just a moment ago
the only thing similar was this barrack
where we were sitting on bunk beds and
we never spoke to one another we had to
learn commands in the foreign language
in German it was December 1943 that I
arrived here and I came here from
Belarus at the time it was occupied by
Germany we civilians got arrested we
were suspected of cooperating with local
Pattinson's so at first we stayed in a
prison and then we loaded onto this
cattle carriage and we were taken away
somewhere we didn't know we're without
any food without a new water no hygiene
to speak of
and that I was together my mum and my
grandparents when the train stopped we
were exhausted and the doors opened and
we saw something even more terrifying
even more terrifying that we had
experienced before
it was the ramp of Auschwitz Birkenau a
concentration camp at the time we had no
idea where we were the was ghastly and
it was leaving those smoking chimneys
nearby there was a row of SS officers
and they did this initial selection some
of them had dogs on leashes and they
were trying to jack away they were
barking at us we were terrified on top
of that it was dark by then there were
those spotlights right on the square and
we were divided at the time we did not
really know what it was all about soon
however we realized that it was
something well suspect some people that
look tired or sick not fit for work
apparently there were not considered the
right working material were directed to
one side and this is why where my
grandparents who were directed and they
were taking to those smoking chimneys my
mum was young she was 22 years old at
the time and with a larger group of moms
with children they looked relatively
ripe and healthy because we never
arrived from the ghetto mind you so we
were directed to the other side which
turned out to be the side side of the
living and we were taken to a place
where our mums had to complete the
undress all that property was taken away
or the souvenirs then they were made to
take a very short shower then they
returned to us children that were
waiting for us and we couldn't recognize
them because their hats were shaven
and they've got those striped uniforms
that you saw at an Exhibition in mosh
pits and they got clubs and then came
its a Turing and this is something a
memory that I share with those ladies
that spoke before so the numbers were
tattooed on our arms even the small
children got tattooed I was only three
years old at the time and I got tattooed
as well so I got this number and I carry
it on my arm till this very day this is
a brand and every day it reminds you
about this terrible time so we got
tattooed the women were put into those
uniforms or struck pajamas and then
children were taken away from the
mothers the children had crying and
shouting mothers were doing the same
thing but there were those other women
who were taking care of it
and later I learned that they were taken
or brought there on purpose there were
criminals from Germany immoral so they
would tear those children away from the
mother's arms
so quite quickly those mothers would be
chased towards the barracks they would
be bitten on the way and us the children
were also taken to one of the barracks
and there I saw many children on bank
bets
we were also maiden to enter there and
there was just some you know just a bit
of straw and there were those blankets
that you could cover yourselves with and
it was dirty rag with insects and they
were quite nasty because they were
crawling all over those bunk beds and
all over the walls and they got the more
active at night they wouldn't let us
sleep we the children had to adapt very
fast very quickly to those conditions
first you had to learn commands in
foreign language and the local lingo
that was used to communicate there
because after all the children spoke
different languages because they came
from different corners of Europe so I
adapted very quickly so it was all about
mentality we quickly turned into those
little creatures like little animals
that fought for survival
and they approached us just the way they
would adults and we would also have just
little bread and this terrible smelly
soup with potato peelings and at first I
would find it difficult to get any soup
at all but then I get a hot because I
learn to fight for survival many
children died
so basically you would take those items
from those that died and we wouldn't
react at all to the death it surrounded
us now the hygiene the hygiene was a
problem there were no toilets you
couldn't clean yourself couldn't wash
yourselves
so do fault disease what we suffered
form it was a kind of diarrhea that
affected also the adults there were no
toilets as I said so basically our life
was about chamber pots we sat on mind
you nobody would take care of us nobody
would wash us so the capo and the
officer would make sure that everything
was orderly walking around with the whip
they wouldn't even touch us because they
were basically to disgust it to touch us
those lousy little creatures and dr.
Mangler was the head physician in this
camp and he conducted pseudo medical
experiments on women children and on
twins especially it was mentioned by the
ladies I was quite a strong child so I
was fit to be experimented on that is
why I lived longer
so I observed other children's and I
learnt from them how to take cover and
hide in a dark corner but at times you
wouldn't be successful and they would
take us this laboratory the laboratories
were very close to the crematorium and
the central lab was in this main camp
this is where we were tested we were
injected with bacteria and vaccines our
blood would be taken and there was this
special fluid that would turn was
supposed to turn the color of our eyes
to make us more Aryan in our imperious
and the doctors himself would pick those
more fit children and I was selected
into this group and then we would return
to barracks and we would live life lice
almost on those bunk beds and yet the
capo
would still take us to the roeckl square
and despite our very very bad condition
at times you would have to stand there
for hours even though it would be heat
or very cold so I did survive and I
survived because I was fit and healthy
and my mum was a young strong woman and
she would be taken outside of the fence
every single day dr. Mengele let me say
a few words about him everybody called
him the angel of death what his
appearance was quite interesting however
he had no human feelings whatsoever he
was obsessed with this Nazi ideology who
wanted to create grow the special man
that would dwell over Europe one day
oh yeah mama because so every single day
my mum a healthy woman would be taken
outside the fence to work very hard they
were supposed to move the course of the
Vistula River mind you they were working
right behind the chambers and crematoria
at this point these are just the
Foundation's that remained Haram Asia
was a village nearby the local people
knew that the camp was suffering from
hunger because it was the most painful
thing for us and those people would
leave some food onions apples bread and
whenever my mom would get some food
she would crawl at dusk to give us some
food which is why I was stronger and
healthier than other children many
mothers would die in female camp they
suffered from typhoid terrible
contagious disease that was the factor
who was lies so
this is how I survived till autumn 1944
it was then that huge transports of
civilians arrived from Warsaw there an
uprising broke out against the Germans
but then the a price was defeated and
those huge transports of people arrived
in Vietnam including young girls Scouts
and we little children would be treated
humanely by them it was the first such
human moment the first human touch that
we had experienced because basically our
discipline was a whip we would not be
given any toys there were there was
nothing to occupy us our lives was
hanging somewhere between a bunk bed and
a chamber pot and that bunk bed that we
were suffering from the orphan disease
so we would be simply sitting there
moving like that there was no solidarity
or friendship among others among us it
was only about the animal fight for
survival what I'm saying I'm sure was
very sad indeed however this is what
happened and I still remember many
things from that time even though I was
a small child and by then I had already
experienced war
so by then I knew that one must be
silent one must be invisible one must
not draw attention
so time comes when people arrive in our
barracks they have different uniforms
those red stars on their hats their
liberators the Soviet Army soldiers and
I remembered this liberation because we
got some bread with margarine it was
this new taste that I hadn't known by
then and some coffee and people for a
motion chi minh nearby town arrived so
those people would take the smallest
children to their homes and thus I found
my way to a Polish home a family took me
in and then experienced a shock for the
first time I saw a regular room at bed
bed linen and I could bathe and I'm
asking are there going to be any rats or
dogs
is there a doctor is that the doctor
Mengele somewhere here is he going to
come to get me so it takes me a lot of
time to get used to normal life I'm
suffering I'm suffering from anemia
however as I said before I was quite a
healthy Charles after few months I can
go outside to meet my peers but this
camp syndrome continues I play out this
camp experience and playing the
selection and the adults are terrified
they say it's so easy to shape people
into tortures murderers and for me it
was so obvious to see an experienced
death and pain
I was not empathic I was kind of ashamed
of the fact that they managed to not be
in this place for so many years and the
number I covered it with a plaster I
didn't want to go back to those memories
and yet something happened I will tell
you a few words about it 17 years later
I met my biological mother she had been
taken to buzz in Bergen and this is
where she got liberated by the airlines
and this is where she also met the
Soviet officers and they told her that
you cannot go that Josh Fitz because the
children are taken to Russia and this is
where my mum went to look for meals she
looked in all these various orphanages
and I on the other hand thought that my
mum died in Auschwitz and I simply came
to terms with all that and I never
looked for my mum because of that is it
okay if I say something more there'll be
questions if I am not mistaken we have
five minutes for questions from students
right do we have questions I think
something was prepared please raise your
arms if you have questions you can
appear Tanya Donna sagashi
to
we have a moment for questions to our
guests
well they were here I'd like to ask the
survivors did you have a special
thoughts special feelings that you had
in the concentration camp that how to
survive this experience as far as we are
concerned the fact of being together
helped us a lot
serger was alone and difficulties with
that and this is probably why he wanted
to join our mother we were together we
all does probably didn't realize many
things we understood all the time
to be honest well I could not understand
the reality to be honest we were just
children Lydia Lydia do you have an
answer on that yes I will answer because
you probably curious to know what my
meeting with my mother was like I was
suggested by those young people to meet
her when I was 18 I turned to the
special search office in Hamburg and
after three years of correspondence I
learned that my mother was not dead as I
believed she was but I learned that she
lived
she lived in the Soviet Union at the
time then the office in Hamburg got in
touch with office in Moscow and that was
a great moment because I was the first
Soviet child returning to homeland and
it was a great success of those offices
immediately I had team coming to me and
they did a recording of my tale of the
tail of and that was really broadcast on
the Russian and Polish national TVs in
nearly all European magazines you could
see my photograph and a short bio then I
was invited to this meeting with mother
which took place in Moscow before I
arrived it was a train from Warsaw to
the Belarusian station in Moscow I
received a special message and thousands
came because they wanted to see those
happy people the doors opened I had a
bouquet of roses for my mother and I saw
thousands of people who were crying
their tears out and they all hoped that
if we managed to find each other they
might as well that's why this was such a
great event propaganda wise and
political thank you we do have another
question a microphone please
no CCSD we were asking ourselves why
does the remember remembers of evil is
not able to change direction it's a
pretty hard question to be honest so I
think we'll take some time to give an
answer it's pretty hard to answer this
question I don't remember
I don't know to be honest why you stake
supremacy over many things why do we
fear why are we afraid of of the
foreigner of the diversity we are all
equal we are all equal
[Applause]
the color the skin the religion the
culture may be different now we are all
equal we are all equal so I think we
need to use our brain and not to be
involved and watch your friend where
your your family says I think for young
people it's very important to be part of
a community of a small community you are
scared of being alone and remember that
it's always better to be alone rather
than being with bad friends one thing I
wanted to turn to you the young people
like I do it in Galician Jewish Museum
here in Kharkov the museum that invites
young people from nearly all over the
world and then I use these words to turn
to them it's in you young hands that the
future of this world lies may you never
allow that won't used to happen here in
Birkenau happens once again because it
depends on you what this world is going
to be q thank you thank you thank you
lidia Thank You Tatiana I'd like to say
one thing something that I forgot
yesterday and I'd like to address my
words to Italian student maybe to Polish
students as well so I think we need to
thank all the people they give you
homework they take of your academic
preparation I think our teachers are the
eros eros of our time they don't
proper salaries without them our journey
wouldn't be possible so let's give them
a round of applause shocking these
testimonies have really been shocking I
believe that both you and I have been
very deeply moved
emotionally thank you very much for
participation in our meeting in this
first part of it and thank you very much
professor we presently are proceeding to
part two of our meeting today
[Applause]
Russia prizefight ladies and gentlemen
in a brief moment we will start the
second part the dialogue
let's reshuffle the stage and in the
meantime we will show you a short video
about what citizens dialogue looks like
in other countries you are the best
educated the healthiest the best
connected the most international most
European generation in European history
[Music]
[Applause]
this is Selena
[Music]
working conditions and in the world
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
yes take Yuka just another moment for
the resetting of the stage and we'll
start our citizens dialogue in a moment
the rules that this plays along please
ask questions if you have some
reflections please make them very short
so that we have an opportunity for
participation of as large number of
people as possible and I hope that our
dialogue will work may I invite the
first vice-president of the European
Commission France timmermans to stage
[Applause]
and also the president of the region of
Tuscany
Enrico Rosi
[Applause]
yeah capiche
the first two addresses is mr. Rossi
[Applause]
first and foremost I would like to thank
our hosts here this prestigious
University and for their warm welcome
and for inviting us to take account of
the fact that relationships between
Italy Tuscany in Florence as the
vice-president of a city reminded us our
date back in town they're linked to
architecture and cultural men
architectures they came here as they
were called from a prestigious
university so these are ancient links
and I was also struck by the stories we
heard today by the attention I was paid
by young people here I was twice and
camps together with our boys and girls I
traveled with them it's an important
experience that leaves a mark and for us
this is decisive investment on youth and
for an on the building of a future maybe
one of the best sentences I've heard is
that the future is in your hand
[Music]
the hands of view of young people from
Italy Poland from all over the world in
a world that is always the grows smaller
every day and
all these stories can build up your
conscience and help you make right
decisions in your life and I think this
is the greatest meaning of this
wonderful morning I would also like to
thank vice president timmermans to be
here and I think his contribution to
your education will be very very
important because in my experience as
president I have had the chance to
understand how Europe is important when
it comes to sticking to values of
tolerance of solidarity and peace that
are key to our future without this
history we would travel back we would go
back we can change but we cannot forget
all positive things that we built so
thank you and I would be happy to answer
your questions and I hope I can meet
your needs and fulfill my task here I
would also like to thank teachers who
are receive love salaries that's truly
needs early and this needs to change but
your work is very precious and this is
also another investment on the future
thank you very much and may I now ask to
the floor mr. president thank you so
much for having me here today I could
have listened to the testimonies for
another hour and a half but now we are
on stage to answer your questions
I can only think about the bravery that
was needed for three young children to
survive the Holocaust and as UI visited
Auschwitz and Auschwitz Birkenau
yesterday and especially when you're you
look at the scale of Auschwitz Birkenau
but if you look at our sheets one if
you're in the exhibition and I don't
know what it did to you but to me seeing
those endless heaps of little children's
shoes seeing this incredible mountain of
human hair what one asks oneself is how
on earth that Europe gets to that point
and this is the question this is the
comment I have or the the subject
perhaps we could we could discuss today
you have seen
you have seen there what happens if we
as human beings unleash our darkest
angels upon other human beings but what
I think is important for you for me and
for your teachers to talk about is how
on earth did we get there
where did all of this start how could
you get to a point that you think it is
normal to bring people and take them
into ovens and you take them into gas
chambers and then burn them in ovens the
guards there had mothers and fathers
they were educated and I am sure their
mothers and fathers never told them you
need to go and kill other human beings
so how did we where does it start
looking at German history of course
Hitler came to power by using hate as an
instrument but even by using hated an
instrument in 1933 when he came to power
had he said in 1933 and now I'm going to
deport all the Jews the German
population would not have supported him
nobody would so what he did is in 1933
start a fundamental campaign of
dehumanizing Jewish people of taking
away their humanity step by step because
they were accused of being enemies of
the people because they were not part of
the civilization because they were part
of an international conspiracy to weaken
Germany because they were creating
diseases because etc etc etc
and he started in 33 and then it five
years after five years he thought let's
see if I have succeeded and then came
the Kristallnacht and then he knew hey
I've succeeded
I have dehumanized them enough when I
start removing them from society the
German population will not rebel at
least not a majority of the German
population I think if we want to honor
the six million people who were killed
in an industrial way during the Second
World War if we want to honor their
memory if we want to make sure they will
never be forgotten we need to revisit
the whole chain of events from the very
start till the very end
murder starts with words words have a
meaning words can create an atmosphere
words can create an attitude leading to
hate leading to exclusion of others
and my friends my friends I cannot be
clearer than that look at our societies
today and hate is again a powerful tool
in the hands of politicians words are
used again to exclude
words are used again to blame somebody
else for your own failures and whenever
this happens in society the first to
experience that have always been in
Europe and will always be the Jews and
then the Muslims and then homosexuals
and then women you always find somebody
to isolate to put in a different place
and if there is something that makes the
European project unique I would agree
with Jorge sempron who said that Europe
was born on the ashes of the
concentration camps of the Nazis that is
where we learnt that we need a different
answer to hate an exclusion that is when
we learned that if we want to make a
better world we need to do it together
as Europeans and not and judge people as
dr. Martin dr. Martin Luther King jr.
said judge people by the strength of
their character not the color of their
skin that is my appeal to you you know
that this is the first European election
in May where people will vote who were
born this millennium you know what that
means to people like myself I was born
in 1961 this millennium don't throw away
your vote don't throw away your vote
because throwing away your vote is like
saying I will give my credit card to
somebody else you don't make the
decision who then uses your credit card
it's nobody else if you don't use your
vote somebody else will decide about
your future come on you're independent
young people decide for yourself
thank you
Bojan query panel sharpener on several
please thank you very much mr. president
ladies and gentlemen we starting the
dialogue the citizens dialog may ask the
first question and immediately then the
microphones go to you in my case this
reflection is very lively we have
forgotten or we do not appreciate what
the EU gave us it gives us a place for
dialogue and cooperation thanks to this
we avoid wars in Europe something
extremely important but sometimes I'm
afraid that we under appreciate that the
more years have passed since the Second
World War but today mr. president we
must stand against a huge problem and
please excuse me please excuse me moving
to one of them namely the problem that
is connected to the disintegration of
the Union and I mean brexit do you
believe mr. president that there is an
opportunity for a beneficial
advantageous solution to that problem do
you believe that the British will
participate in European elections and
brexit will at least be postponed answer
like that but I want to say a few things
about brexit of course we all respect
the sovereign decision of the British
people they have the rights it's written
in the treaty to leave the European
Union if that is what they decide and
they decided in a referendum to do that
but I this was one of my saddest moments
in my in my life in my political career
when this happened and I were to say
very clearly I respect their decision we
will have to wait for what they decide
in the House of Commons and the
government but were they to decide
otherwise
and who in this room has never ever
changed their minds on anything it's
also part of being human that you look
at something again and you think eh
perhaps not perhaps different nothing
wrong with that but that's up to them to
decide but when and if they would decide
that I think every single one in this
room would be happy because they belong
to our family the United Kingdom in my
view still belongs to the European
family British citizens are just as much
Europeans as you and I and it would make
me tremendously happy were they to
reconsider but it's not up to us
it's up to them
sorry yesyes but the British government
expects that European Union alleles and
renegotiates we negotiated in good faith
for a long time we looked at the red
lines Teresa may put on the table we
also had our own red lines obviously and
I think the withdrawal agreement we
reached is the optimal solution taking
into account the interests of both sides
and there are some things that cannot be
done cannot be done and especially on
the backstop the 27 agreed that we will
not abandon Ireland we will support
Ireland and we will help Island Ireland
achieve having no hard border on the
island of Ireland because you know to
make it perfectly clear when in 1998
Tony Blair and the Irish government and
they two main parties in Ireland reached
the Good Friday Agreement this was a
historic change in Europe the island had
been in the hands of terrorists for so
long so much violence everywhere that
this Good Friday Agreement was a
historic European document but for the
Good Friday Agreement to function you
need to avoid a hard border in Ireland
between the north and the Republic and
if you
introduce a hard border there the risks
of violence coming back are too big and
I think we have a collective European
responsibility towards all citizens in
on the island of Al whether they're
British or Irish to prevent violence
coming back there to prevent the
troubles from the past coming back there
and that is why for us the back stop is
a red line that we cannot negotiate with
the British government Russia Italia may
I now have questions please could you
pass the microphone to the lady over
here will be to you vice president but
firstly let me thank you from the bottom
of my heart of my heart for your great
effort and for a determination to
support us for the defending rule of law
and democracy in Poland thank you very
very much
my question will be building on what you
said earlier about where this whole
tragedy begins which is which with hate
with hate speech with with the
dissemination of hate also considering
what happened recently here in Gdansk
the tragedy in the manuscript my
question is about what the Commission is
planning to do are there any plans in
terms of legislation in the upcoming
term to somehow try to tackle this issue
of hate speech of disinformation of fake
news and more importantly as this
Israeli historian you well know Acharya
says recently we can you can we can talk
about some what brain hacking human
brain hacking by algorithms and it's not
only because of commercial for
commercial purposes its announced for
political purposes affecting elections
affecting the future of Europe so my my
question is how the Commission Israel is
planning to tackle that thank you thank
you very much and I will I will give you
a precise answer on your questions but
let me let me start let me start by
paying tribute to the political
determination and the humanity of
President adamovich who was a great
European and a great pole
and let me take let me take some of the
lessons some of the lessons he taught us
powerup adamovich when he was attacked
never hit back because he knows you
cannot drive out hate with hate Bhavan
adamovich when there were attacks on gay
people he didn't shout back he organized
a Gay Pride which was a great success
Inc - bhava adamovich when there was a
campaign to scare people about refugees
pamela adamovich got together with other
mayor's in poland and said they are
welcome in our cities that is the way
you address hate you cannot drive hate
out with hate only love drives out hate
completely
recently at the conference in Brussels
we discuss about this issue how do you
deal with fake news etc etc you know
that those perpetrators of terrorist
attacks in Europe they were educated or
brought to hate or brought to use
violence very often on the Internet by
people glorifying violence by people
telling lies about others by people
actually demonstrating how you make
bombs etc so there is a threat there and
we need to act and the Commission has
come up with a number of proposals to
act on these issues so yes we will
continue to do that pops frankly I
believe there is a more fundamental
issue we need to address and Appelbaum
I'm sure you've heard of her said
recently she compares the information
revolution we're going through now to
the coming of the printing press by
Gutenberg that had revolutionized the
way people communicated in Europe the
printing press demo democratizing
reading etc you could and this is
actually a phenomenon of equal magnitude
social media the internet artificial
intelligence all of that has the same
paradigm shifting effect on our society
and you know that legislation is not
going to be the only and even the most
important answer to that you know this
one thing that is most important and
that addresses all of you and especially
your teachers the only thing that will
save us is this essential human capacity
of critical thinking if we continue to
teach our children
if we continue to teach them the
capacity of critical thinking of not
accepting anything that is thrown at
them but looking at it questioning
questioning their parents questioning
their teachers being taught by their
parents to be critical to chew on things
because I think the biggest threats to
humanity is the loss of the capacity of
critical thinking of groupthink of
almost tribal attitudes it might not be
true but the tribe says it's right so
I'll stick to it no history tells us we
are individuals who can make individual
choices and who have individual rights
don't fall into the trap of tribalism
think for yourselves draw your own
conclusions and stand up as proud young
Europeans for your convictions and take
others with you that is the way we are
going to solve this challenge
[Applause]
[Music]
can we have some more questions yes
please and a request could you please
also introduce yourselves and please be
short in your questions well good
afternoon I'm Carol Merrick I'm studying
a political science student from this
beautiful outstanding University and I
have a question to vice president three
days ago
you have written a tweet let me read it
now so young people standing behind me
you must come with us and shape your own
future and the question is why we should
follow you and follow people like you
you said Europe European Union was
founded was funded on the ashes now
those were ashes faded away so amongst
young people across the Europe
especially in the Central Europe
especially on the south turn Europe
there is a profound conviction that the
European Union doesn't respond for our
needs and for our expectation anymore
so now please convince me to follow and
to support this obsolete model of
European Union thank you so are you are
you going to
are you going to continue to complain
about an obsolete model or are you going
to get energized get organized and
change it I'm not saying you need to
follow me I'm saying you need to shape
the future in your image in the way you
want it not I'm not saying you should do
what I said I'm just giving you an
example take it or leave it
if you have a better idea good for you
but what I don't accept is people
complaining complaining putting
something on Facebook I'm not saying
you're doing that not saying you're
doing that your class your class sir is
to make me superfluous because you will
take the reins and shape the future but
as long as you don't do it I will
continue to act on the values I believe
in and you could disagree with me or
agree with me but take the
responsibility in your hands because if
you don't do it somebody else will and
they might not be in Europe they might
be somewhere else
and why do I believe in the
now coming to the challenge and you know
guy I like the fact that you challenge
me I wish more people would do it so
thank you very much for that
why why why do I believe do you think
because the alternative that is
presented to us is actually three things
going around one group saying we need to
destroy your because it's not delivering
one group says we need to maintain
Europe as it is and that one group says
and I hope I can convince you that I'm
part of that we need your but it needs
to change quite drastically to deliver
the results that we need for the future
but this incredibly bad thought through
idea that individual member states on
their own would be better placed to face
challenges like climate change like the
threat from Russia like the
unpredictability of the United States
like the rise of China the the idea that
Europeans we are only seven percent of
the world's population all of us
together the idea that we could be
better placed to to serve our citizens
as individual countries rather than as
Europeans together is an idea I just
don't understand you know for me the
European Union is not a goal in itself
for me the European Union is a tool to
build a society based on the values of
our citizens if in the future you or
others find a better tool kudos great
and I will support it but for now it's
still the best show in town but we need
to make sure that for instance the fact
that so many young people especially in
Italy still remain on the sidelines
because they are not given an
opportunity I have too many Italian
friends who tell me this over
the fact that coming out of the crisis
income differences in societies almost
all European societies have hugely
increased bankers are doing very very
well indeed again but the people who
paid to keep the banks of business did
not get any returns yet this needs to
change very urgently what also needs to
change is we need a plan to bring Europe
into a sustainable world sustainable
world is going to happen
the only question is who's going to
shape it are we going to shape it or is
somebody else going to shape it you know
I see the rise of nationalism
all across Europe and I also see that
many too many young people are attracted
by it but I tell you one thing they are
very very good at destroying things I
haven't ever seen them build anything
the only thing that their attitude leads
to is
paralysis look at those countries and
societies where they are in charge its
paralysis they don't move forward and
please don't get me wrong I'm not
telling you what to do the only thing
I'm telling you is take your future in
your hands
shape it in your image be responsible
for your and our future I have four kids
I four kids I want them to live in a
society where hate is not present where
people work together where there's more
solidarity than we see today and I
believe that if we see each other as
human beings are not as part of a tribe
we will get there as Europeans but Sir
great that you want an alternative I
want an alternative as well but I think
there's more to be gained by reforming
the European Union than destroying the
European Union next question please
Djibouti son Alexander gods ET Lois I
good afternoon everyone I'm Alessandro
Gazette I am president of parliament for
Tuscany students
like to thank my region my president the
European Commission for this dialogue
opportunity that we were granted and
it's really important to start from
today to build our future we cannot
start tomorrow to build the future of us
of us young people we have to be active
and work for it thank you very much for
this opportunity
looking around me in this room I see
many Italian polish boys and girls
sitting close to one another and I see
Europe here Europe is here we are Europe
this is Europe that's that's Europe we
are Europe often we hear that Europe
it's not something concrete something
higher that is detached from us and so
far away I don't agree with that Europe
is the most concrete thing that we can
see we can experience I come from Livan
in Tuscany and the lack of my town was
that it was an open city welcoming
foreigners and we moved thanks to that
to town a fisherman to a big city where
different cultures the Jewish culture
the Orthodox colleges the Dutch culture
we have everything in Livorno and
without the fact the welcoming of people
as dine skirts the vice president of
drawings said earlier today that's
something beautiful and I am going to
ask president Rossi and you so what can
Tuscany do what can you open to to have
these hospitality welcoming spirits to
welcome other people to live diversity
as an advantage and not as a
disadvantage and what can we
- as young boys and girls because
tomorrow's in our hands and I hope one
day this might be the room of the
European Commission because bbc's of
people I'm seeing today are beautiful
faces so I asked him what can you and
what can we do so that Europe becomes
something with a strong feeling and not
something that's far away and something
to foster hospitality and welcoming of
foreigners thank you in tempo yo credo
the D amico suppose so let's see what in
our region can we can do I don't know if
you know but in Tuscany where we are
four hundred thousand migrants four
hundred thousand migrants
in our region but let's be honest we do
live in a multi-ethnic society there are
people with different cultures and
backgrounds more or less and talking
about Europe there are 90 thousand ten
one hundred thousand people coming from
Romania they work in different fields
and there are 100,000 from Albania
nineteen eighty seven eighty nine and
after the notice and they are perfectly
integrating there they are working in
the green sector and then we have an
anemic known EU migrants
who maybe be harder to have a dialogue
so the Europe is Europe ease and help to
integrate people known EU immigration is
made up of Chinese sub Syrian people
northern Africa so I think we need to
work all together to integrate them so
that rights are granted so that people
are not left alone
the right to become Italian citizen is
relevant to them I think this is where
we need to take into consideration you
attend schools with people who were
grown up with you because of the fact
that I have a different color of skin
they don't have right to be Italian
citizenship to be an Italian citizen
this is discrimination
so the first this is the first example
that comes now to my mind and then of
course we need to be proactive in a
field of tolerance and dialogue
there are many negative things which are
happening in our daily lives this is
what I'm reading Pisa to young people
and they flow to the fluid detergent
they through a detergent to a black
black guy how do you call that detergent
yeah powder detergent something like
that bleach yeah this is not racism some
people say this is not racism this is
not true this is not this is racist
I think we need to fight against racism
we need to build up a culture when these
situation arises we should be ready to
I've been to Auschwitz as well everybody
as a fault
everybody has some feelings about
Auschwitz I gotten information from the
Polish survival I got something that
that really cheered me up the first
question I asked myself was could gods
and old people were living then not know
about it how could you bear with that
how could you bear with this evil I mean
chimney people were broked outside comes
to work I think we need to be to act in
order not to be in the same situation we
cannot be indifferent I am sure that the
vice president knows more about it we
cannot tolerate the fact that people die
we have a duty to help people who are
dying
[Applause]
otherwise we turn a blind eye to that we
do not even give our small piece of
bread to people suffering this is what
comes to my mind we cannot turn a blind
eye to that
don't you know very well ditalion writer
in the third chance there are doing
difference those who do not stand by
anyone those who do not deserve to go to
hell to heaven those who are roaming
around and and they didn't take any
decision they didn't take any position
on that and this is what I heard from
voice the present in memory we cannot
turn a blind eye remember that
what can we didn't be working in Italy
with refugees four years ago three years
ago while I was going to Sicily I always
asked the same question how to help
these poor people nobody in Sicily told
me sand damn Oh nobody nobody in system
in Sicily told me sand and no home what
else in Italy is a great science being
left alone by Europe this is this is
what I heard I felt while I was in Italy
this we did everything in the Commission
to help Italian people with with funds
with initiatives and so on there was a
huge lack of solidarity at the European
level among the Member States this is
something I have to say in Poland is in
Poland
let's be clear on that
when a European citizen understand the
need of being of sharing solidarity with
Italy and Greece would not share the
same geographical position if we do not
share this view with all the countries
Italian people will feel left alone
Italy was a very pure opinion and now he
became a bit error sceptic we are
attacked by the Italian government on an
everyday basis and the same thing
applies the other way around when polls
say we do have historical knowledge
about Russia
we know the threats coming from the east
right to solidarity from all European
countries and this is the basis the
fundamental the problems of your
neighbors are always are also your
problems otherwise we are all left alone
and we are not able to solve problems
Russia could we have the next question
please
hello sorry hello thank you for the
floor I would like to introduce myself
my name is Barbara Robinson I'm the
young European ambassador in Poland so
I'm so I'm briefly representing polish
youth in European Union dear mr.
president in December you said that the
elections of this year of 2019 are not
an ordinary elections and also that we
have to write a new social contract with
European citizens so may I kindly ask
you to explain to us why do we need it
and how would it look like
thank you I believe if you look at at
the political forces in all of our
Member States and you look at the rise
of anti-european movements that are
becoming stronger why you know why are
voters going to those anti European
nationalist movements because they
shared the ideology perhaps apart but I
think also because they are
disillusioned disillusions by the
European Union disillusioned by the
traditional parties who have not
delivered what they had hoped for and if
I call this election an election about
the soul of Europe I say this because
the choice before us is going to be
quite clear do we believe that we can
improve the lives of our citizens if
every member state goes into a fighting
mode towards the other member states do
we believe in a Europe where we fight to
get things done or do we still believe
in a Europe where we share
destiny and we then also have to share
solidarity and then I come to my to the
second and I I strongly believe in a
second let me be very clear about that
but solidarity is not mere altruism
solidarity also has an element of
self-interest in it I take care of
somebody else who's in trouble and I
count on that person also helping me
when I'm in trouble that's the basic
element in our families in society in
how we relate to others and this feeling
in Europe was lost
the feeling was lost ordinary citizens
were told we have to put billions and
billions of taxpayers money into saving
banks because otherwise the economic
system would suffer and citizens did
reluctantly but they did the bank's
recovered quite well and are doing
extremely well and the citizens are
asking themselves so I did this and what
is in this for me look at salaries they
have not the the salaries do not reflect
the growth in our economy's insecurity
that has come to the labor markets you
know you you you get a job but the job
is extremely insecure you know in in my
own country at some points but the judge
is corrected it
that's why you need independent judges
but it's another discussion the what we
had in my country was that a 16 year old
boy riding a bike with a deliver rule
rucksack on his back was considered an
entrepreneur how ridiculous is that and
if he fell and he was ill he didn't get
any compensation no medical costs etc so
if I say we need to rewrite the social
contract we need to create a Europe that
actually protects its citizens
and it is so necessary because the world
is changing at lightning speed and as I
said before we are only seven percent of
the world's population and we are only
strong if we stick together we're only
strong if we understand what the Polish
citizens want and respect that and work
on that and at the same time understand
what the Italian citizens want and bring
these two things together they're not
exactly the same things but we could
create a balance and if the idea is lost
that you find progress in compromise and
that you can only find progress in
zero-sum games because that is what many
politicians are now saying I win so you
need to lose what is wrong with both of
us winning a bit and compromising on
something if that idea is lost the noble
art of compromising then we will not
bring Europe forward and it will be
every man every woman on their own and
the final comment I want to make on the
social contract it's very important in
my view very important to do with it
what you like but what I see in these
sort of neo-traditional neo nationalist
movements is they also want to restore
they want to take us back 50 years and
they especially also want to put women
in the same place women were fifty years
ago and I say to all women and all men
because feminism should also be a man's
cause I say to all women and all men in
this room be extremely careful don't let
our mothers our sisters our daughters be
put in a weak position with a reference
to tradition or family values
no we will not allow this to happen
the person astern nepeta next question
please can we have the next question
please good afternoon I'm a student and
wanted to report what is said is being
said in Italy my territory about the
European Union because by reading things
and social media is that the European
Union is not an alliance of peoples but
an alliance based on economic treaties
and on foreign banks which produces even
greater austerity and deprives meat a
class of money so that's what I wanted
to know why what do you think about that
and then a specific question for
president Rossi I hear that from in my
home and from all my friends the health
care system in Tuscany is going towards
a progressive privatization and I
sometimes hear that in my home and then
maybe for black people for migrants
these faces and exams are for free while
we have to pay for them and that's a
sign of civilization if you want so
avoid excessive costs that can produce
discrimination against those who are
exempted from payments thank you thanks
for the translators who had to just lay
down the health care system in Tuscany
is public and there's a ticket so a fee
that we didn't put into force and was
put into force way before us so for some
exams this ticket this fear so it's
laboratory tests nothing really costly
these makes it competitive to turn to
the private health care agencies but
interventions and surgeries definitely
the least important ones as well as the
most important ones are being carried
out in the public health system so the
idea that Tuscany health system is
privatizing is wrong and I would like
even to discuss it with your parents if
they won't that's not like that there's
a problem with financing yes we've heard
a lot about debt and we have to say the
truth in Tuscany 95% of funds are public
there's a problem with financing that
maybe the vice president knows well
so for years we have now been under the
threshold of 6.5 percent of the GDP and
on the old experts in this matter all
experts say that under this threshold of
6.5% the healthcare system has troubles
so these problems exist both in Tuscany
and all in the whole country so I would
have to make a wider discussion here and
I think we need better investment in
healthcare system in in education and
universities and in the territory
management but I can assure you that the
healthcare system in Tuscany is public
as far as the taking care of everyone is
concerned I say yes yes we need to take
care and treat everyone everyone article
32 of our Constitution speaks volumes
about that it says it's clearly states
that have fees rights is an individual
right and a collective interest because
our fathers who fought during the
worldwide World War two they decided to
write that in the eyes of a collective
interest because everyone needs to be
safe and healthy in our territory we had
an initiative for vaccines and
vaccinations because everyone should be
vaccinated and obviously if I don't go
there it's obvious that I lose a battle
if I don't treat someone and I don't
then that person who is not treated by
me then they could spread sickness the
illnesses that they bring so it as well
as an ethical principle it is also in
the collective interest of the whole
population
so we are also Catholics so the Good
Samaritan parable should also be taught
and reconsiders so how can I allow that
as a Good Samaritan I see a person that
is wounded that was beaten up and the
Good Samaritan takes that person that
takes this person to a hotel to shelter
and leaves the money there so that they
treats him and then he said if you spend
more then I will stop by again and I
will give you what you need that's a
civilization and Catholic and religious
parable a teaching before anything else
someone says that Europe needs to be
based on these values as well and I say
yes that is true in Tuscany we put into
force a law that says the court is right
we want to treat everyone who is in our
territory and to make sure that everyone
who is in our territory that they have
basic treatment I think that's the right
way to look at the future and to be all
healthy because as it was said before it
is true that at least in the eyes of
illness and sicknesses we should all be
equal who is wealthy and who is not so
his poor who comes from far away and who
was born there that's a great win for us
and we won't step back on this in
tuscany and i will fight to the very end
but approach honest and epitaphs could
we have the next question please
hi vice president you said that most of
the people get along with nationalist
ideas we were not talked what Europe is
freedoms like the year you understand
the importance of freedoms when you lack
of freedom we take for granted a Europe
is irrelevant
there are many people saying that Europe
is obsolete and this is old-fashioned
those yeah well try to make it shorter I
will try to make it shorter Dominica
[Applause]
so otherwise you get angry where are you
from from Tuscany from where from pistoi
from the province of pistoia okay okay
I lost the Fred sorry and the question
is the following
can we disseminate the idea that Europe
is not something obsolete
Europe is not a dream this is I read the
manifest of entertain Europe is not the
dream we are not dreamers what the
European Commission can do nor the
Europe or the single currency or the
Europe that takes care of Italian
accounts Europe who takes care of people
coming to the méditerranée
[Applause]
what is Europe what is Europe this is
the institution in Brussels the
Commission now we are small to love
Europe Europe is ooh
Europe is you in the towns and villages
in Europe in Italy in Poland Noland this
is where Europeans the only questions is
the following so let people say the
Europe is something obsolete or we try
to to raise our voice those who attack
Europe on everyday basis are really
aggressive most of the citizens or most
of the European citizens are silent
don't want to to take the floor I don't
want to discuss with people and this
dialogue this is not a dialogue diseases
sometimes a kind of violence aggression
a speech there is a lot of violence
aggression from the part of the Italian
government as well
[Music]
and this is because some people are not
hurt don't we don't need to do eight
other people so let's try to build up a
better Europe we are the shapers of
Europe probably won't be the same Europe
yesterday today bow if we started today
the Europe Europe will be better
tomorrow and the day after we will share
solidarity
do not leave migrants dying in the
Mediterranean this is what we need to do
all together and we stand aside people
who want to do that but we are just a
small to love yourself questions yes
please the last question ok hello my
name is Alexandra protec and I would
like to ask you a question about brexit
because well social democratic values
are very close to my heart and I felt
very grateful for the opportunity to
study abroad but with their light of
recent events connecting to brexit I am
pretty worried if like what my future
will be because my ideal you would want
to study in England or Scotland and well
live there in the future hopefully so my
question is where the line stands
between European Union and Europe what
what are the perspectives of students
because when I read articles about
brexit there's really no mentioning
students and as a person that applies in
September to universities abroad I'm
worried and very uncertain about my
future thank you
just a few thoughts
I had the great advantage of living in
many parts of Europe during my life my
father was a soldier first and then he
worked for the Foreign Service and so we
traveled a lot and then I studied abroad
then I became a diplomat myself you know
what the biggest gift is if you spend
time in another country and I don't mean
holiday for a week or two it's but
serious time you discover who you are it
is in rubbing up to people who are
different that you identify your own
identity that you understand who you are
living in another country made me more
Dutch than I was before going there but
at the same time it also brought a deep
love to me of other countries I lived in
Italy for four years as a teenager I've
been Romulo and the Romani stuff for the
rest of my life this is something that
was
yes and even though even though we are
weaker than before we'll still beat the
hell out of your fury to the point you
were making it is if you have the
capacity and all of you here have the
capacity it is almost a duty to spend
time as a student in an other country to
become better citizens of your own
country and to also start to understand
what it means to be European the United
Kingdom whether some of them like it or
not will remain a deeply European
country and I mean this in a cultural
sense in a geopolitical sense in an
economic sense
yes brexit will do harm and perhaps if
they are not very careful great harm but
it will not I mean the geography will
not change the interests will not change
and also British academia has been a
huge huge contribution to all of Europe
and all of the world you know I think I
can say this in this university we do
admire the universities in the United
Kingdom and what they have done for the
whole of Europe and I really hope we can
find ways of keeping them very close to
us and having a lot of students there
but it might become more expensive if
they have different fees I don't know I
can't predict that but as someone who I
was raised in it in an English
educational system I lived in Italy I've
learned to love those countries almost
as much as my own country in the course
of my work I've learned to love other
countries and that is what for me is
being European in the love of other
countries you discover the beauty of
your own culture and your own country
that is such a richness I can't tell you
how enriching that experience is and you
somebody talked about air and that
you're not aware of the air I always say
it's like a fish in the water if if
if you ask a fish in the water define
water the fish will not be able to do
that if you take the fish out of the
water just 1 2 3 4 seconds the wish fish
will know exactly what water is I want
to go back at 2 that is the same with
culture and if I can end on this because
I understand this was the last question
now what I want to really really leave
you with a heartfelt message stay true
to your beliefs I'm not saying it should
be the same beliefs as mine don't get me
wrong stay true to your beliefs stay
true to your individuality and your
personal rights stay true to this
incredible richness of the European
culture I would not be standing here
probably you never know if my father as
a young boy was not liberated by Polish
soldiers in the Netherlands stay true to
our history understand where we came
from understand the sacrifices British
polish and other soldiers did to make us
free see this freedom not as something
that is god-given it's hard work day day
to day see this freedom as a huge legacy
that is given to you by your parents and
your teachers and a huge responsibility
upon your shoulders to make sure that
this freedom is strengthened and
maintained this is my appeal to you make
Europe better for us you can thank you
Bojan create the world functional study
thank you very much this was the answer
to the last question I know there have
been many other questions but I hope
that our guests will visit us again in
Poland and there will be an opportunity
to ask these questions again thank you
very much mr. president mr. president
and to you ladies and gentlemen thank
you very much for participating in this
citizens dialogue
[Applause]
[Music]
yes
you know Kelly